So good job cleaning up the media
player resources as soon as you
didn't need them anymore.
So you're already following the best
practices of Android development,
well at least for the most part.
Now I want to tell you some more details
that will require us to modify our code
just a little bit more.
So the issue is that we've been
operating under the assumption
that the user will always
stay within our app.
Well what if the user decides to
switch away to say a web browser or
even head over to a phone call?
Well if the user is not
actively looking at our app,
we can't finish executing our code and
clean up the media player resources.
So if the user switches over to several
other apps and never comes back to
Army Walk app then eventually
Android will destroy our activity.
So that it can use those resources to
run the more recent apps that the user's
interacting with.
So as a developer,
we have to be ready for
the user to leave our
activity at any time.
Or for the system to destroy our
activity because it needs those
resources for something else.
So for example, in an email app
the developer's responsible for
storing the latest version
of the user's email draft.
So that when the user returns
to the app, even after days or
months, it appears as if
they've never left the app.
Now in this case, the developer
should indicate to the system
that it's interested in knowing when
the user leaves the current activity.
And at that point,
the developer should save off
the latest version of the email draft.
So later when the user
comes back to the activity,
the email draft should
be populated on screen.
So it would be bad if they came back to
the email draft that they were writing
and the screen was just completely blank
because the changes that they made
were never saved off.
So all this behavior is driven
by the need to conserve
memory resources on a device.
So Android wants to have enough
resources so that the current app that
the user is interacting with is fast,
responsive and the resources
aren't wasted on apps that the user
hasn't interacted with in a while.
So in order to provide structure to all
the chaos that could be happening on
a device, Android has a life cycle
that all the activities can follow.
So the system will handle
transitioning the activity from
one stage of the lifecycle to another
and it offers call backs so that you as
a developer can get notified when
these changes happen in your activity.
So when you get notified,
you can take that opportunity to execute
certain instructions that you need.
So let's discuss other states
that the activity can be in.
When a activity is first launched
it's created, and then started, and
then resumed.
Now, at this point the activity's active
and the user can interact with it.
So as soon as the user moves to
a different activity or a different app,
then this activity moves into a paused
state, and then to a stop state.
And if it is closed out,
then it becomes destroyed.
So if the user comes back to this
activity then it gets restarted,
and we moved back into
the started state and
now the user can interact
with it once again.
So here I've shown you a simplified
activity lifecycle diagram.
So that you could first grasp a high
level overview of what's happening.
So in the official Android documentation
in the starting activity section,
we have a full activity
lifecycle diagram here.
So this diagram is a little bit more
complex than the one I showed you
earlier but the main idea is the same.
So remember that the Android
system is responsible for
transitioning your activity
into each of these states.
So you as a developer can't control
which state that you're in.
So starting from here,
when your activity is launched,
the activity is moved into a created
state using the onCreate method.
And then it's moved into the started
state using the on start method.
So at this point it becomes
visible to the user.
And so from there it's moved into the
resume state via the on resume method.
And in this case the activity
is still visible to the user.
But the user can now start
interacting with the activity.
So here you can display animations,
use sensors like location sensors or
even use a camera on the device.
So the activity can stay in the resume
state for however long the user is
looking at the screen, so that could
be minutes or hours or even longer.
Now as soon as your user
switches to a different activity,
then your activity is paused
via the on pause method, and
from there it moves into a stop
state via the on stop method.
So at this point the activity is
no longer visible to the user.
So, since you user
can't see the activity.
If the system determines that your
activity is no longer needed,
the system may destroy your
activity via the on destroy method
in order to free up
resources on the device, and
then your activity would
enter the destroyed state.
But otherwise, your activity could
just stay in the stop state.
Then if your user decides to come back
to the activity before it's destroyed,
then the activity is restarted
via the onRestart method and
then it moves back into the started
state via the onStart method.
And then finally back into the resume
state via the onResume method.